el presidente francés emmanuel makoun
denunció este sábado crímenes
inexcusables para la republica al
término de una ceremonia oficial por el
aniversario número 60 de la masacre de
argelinos cometida el 17 de octubre de
1961 en parís
los crímenes cometidos esa noche bajo la
autoridad de móviles para pong son
inexcusables para la republica francia
mira toda su historia con lucidez y
reconoce las responsabilidades
claramente establecidas la conmemoración
tuvo lugar en el puente de beso en la
periferia parisina donde hace 60 años
30.000 argelinos que habían acudido a
manifestarse pacíficamente fueron
violentamente reprimidos querían a la
vez protestar contra el toque de queda
nocturno que la policía impuso días
antes sólo a los argelinos de la zona y
mostrar su solidaridad con sus
compatriotas que estaban luchando por la
independencia de su país estos
manifestantes iban a sufrir la represión
más mortífera en europa occidental desde
la polis s la policía quería dislocar
las procesiones para usar el lenguaje
policial y como se disloca una procesión
en esa época la isla casa punta de pique
estás entonces la policía cargó con esos
palos de madera romper cráneos no hay
otras palabras para describir lo que
pasó esa noche cuando juego
el balance oficial tres muertos y unos
62 muy lejos de la realidad según los
historiadores quienes hablan de entre 30
y 200 muertos y le gustó ya es hora de
que en este aniversario 60 el estado
reconozca por fin su responsabilidad con
una palabra fuerte al más alto nivel
sobre esta masacre de civiles hubo que
esperar a 2001 para que se colocará una
placa conmemorativa en parís y a 2012 y
para que el presidente i phones foulon
reconociera una represión sangrienta